vous propose de partir à présent la
découverte d'un café restaurant pas
comme les autres son nom c'est le café
joyeux et les situé avenue de grammont à
tours sa particularité c'est qu'il
emploie des équipiers des équipières qui
présentent un handicap mental ou des
troubles cognitifs le concept existait
déjà paris bordeaux ou encore à rennes
le café joyeux tourangeau a été inauguré
ce midi un reportage signé sébastien
branger je voulais juste vous dire qu'il
ya plus de tact mentale en jambes il
désolé
cloué à 24 ans c'est son premier jour de
travail au café joyeux well c'est une
bonne opportunité qui l'emmène
sereinement sur le chemin de la
professionnalisation
et vente du coup avec moi sens très bien
je vais vous dire que
j'aime ce que je fais je fais de la
cuisine
du ménage je fais ce que j'aime ici ce
sont sept équipiers comme chloé en
situation de handicap qui se démène dans
la joie pour servir les clients parfois
surpris toujours touché par le lien
profondément humain que ses employés pas
comme les autres essaient de tisser la
salle richelieu c'est là qu'a fait les
beaux quand on se promène dans la rue
déjà les jaunes cette instance est plein
de joie et moi je trouve que de faire
travailler des personnes
pas forcément une place dans la société
aujourd'hui c'est extrêmement important
et anti-saleh hyper bon donc franchement
y'a pas se réveiller à l'initiative de
ce projet entrepreneurial et social
c'est yann bucaille la rosa qu un patron
au grand coeur pour qu'ils l'inclusion
n'est pas un vain mot c'est incroyable
l'autonomie que nos équipiers jo et ont
pu acquérir ça commence par le transport
mais c'est aussi c'est aussi tout
simplement la façon de se tenir la façon
de s'habiller la façon d'interagir avec
des personnes vous savez dans un café
joyeux les gens rentrent sorte ils
viennent sans rendez vous c'est même pas
un restaurant où l'on réserve c'est que
c'est ouvert à tous dans des personnes
qui portent un handicap sont tout à fait
capables effectivement de créer une
relation avec nos convives situé sur
l'avenue grammont à deux pas de la place
jean jaurès le café joyeux ne vous
servira qu'avec le coeur